si tou tv proposera pas moins de 40
nouvelles séries originales aux poissons
pêchés si t'as pas d'abord la très
attendue
les avants vis de retour après la pause
6 degrés la première série dramatique
signée simon boulerice et l'oeil du
cyclone qui marque le retour au jeu de
virer de luthiers et qui met en vedette
christine beaulieu
les vrais engagements sur les enfants
parce qu'une faction sorti fin août et
russe et pour moyenné rentrer là dedans
c'est doux c'est plein d'amour dans la
comédie très réaliste jouer dans une
série télé j'ai professeur depuis 2002
donc je suis plus calme même temps un
retour parce que j'avais pas mal oublier
comme un frein mais ça s'est bien passé
tous eu à surveiller également laurent
paquet et geneviève alarie seront en
vedette dans la série je t'aime
j'avais envie de ramener un couple mais
un groupe qui voit bien des gens que
j'aime ici d'où tv netflix cribe illico
les plateformes des cotons continue son
très populaire particulièrement en
pandémie
le ministre du patrimoine steven
guilbeault veut d'ailleurs forcé ces
acteurs de l'industrie à investir dans
la production de contenu canadien
la loi sur la radiodiffusion date de
1991 avant internet
il a présenté mardi un projet de loi en
ce sens les entreprises qui bénéficient
du système doivent contribuer au système
on va suivre le projet de loi que son
développement netflix le leader dans le
domaine souhaite aussi continuer à
étudier le projet de loi et déclare que
tous ont un rôle à jouer pour soutenir
l'avenir du cinéma et de la télévision
j'en suis d'accord affirme pour sa part
qu'il était temps de réviser cette loi
mais indique que certaines inquiétudes
demeurent alors que du côté de
l'association québécoise de la
production médiatique on se réjouit de
cette annonce
c'est à une demande qu'on faisait depuis
déjà près de cinq ans on est ravi de ce
premier pas évidemment mais on est loin
de la coupe aux lèvres
certaines plateformes n'offrent pour le
moment que très peu de contenu canadien
mais malgré les bonnes intentions ces
changements ne se font pas du jour au
lendemain
ici les biens alexandre chartier radio
canada montréal